There's no such thing as a ninja using two swords,
right? My name is Akakamiji.  I
would like to evaluate the realism of ninjas by watching them in movies and television.  It's the kind of
gunpowder that
provokes them inside, or that kind of
brightness.  The
most important thing is to find out what the enemy is doing and tell your allies, is
n't it?  It's
not the core part of any one practical skill, but it's
definitely an important part of it.  To
put it bluntly, it's the practical skills of modern spies and special
forces. It's
difficult, isn't it?
By the way,
ambushes are also included in that sort of thing.  Early
in the morning,
when you go back to sleep, the
bow and arrow
are a technique of ninja, and one of them
has the privilege of not making a sound.  There's
no doubt that
ninja didn't use shuriken that much.  It's
hard to even hit the enemy, and it's hard to get hit,
and even if you get hit, the opponent wo
n't die easily.  It
doesn't mean that black is the only
black
costume.
This is a normal person,
isn't it?
Because it moves by itself or moves in narrow spaces, it was
more convenient to have a
sword with short eyes.  It's
scene 5, isn't it? It's
not a mistake to use the chain used in that movie.
It's a samurai weapon that isn't exclusive, especially in the Edo period. It's a weapon that women
learned to
use.  I do
n't
have one, but I do sometimes use it by jumping.
When I was young, I used to do it often.It's a
nighttime activity, and there
are many ninjas, including those who are
shinobi.
It's an exercise to sharpen the senses of the whole body. There's
something similar to the training just now.  It's on
the ground or between ordinary boards, so there's
no such thing as
going under it.  It
's an advantageous weapon for fighting the enemy, isn't it?
This is a sickle spear and a spear.  It's
difficult to use in a narrow room, but it's
made short so that you can
fight even in a small room.I
think shinobi often worked in teams.
When you do,
of course, you
do it as a team.
There's no set rule for
ninjas to use two swords.
[Music] I
don't think I'm bad at brown sugar, even as a
ninja.  It's a very important martial art, so I
think I practiced it the most.
[Laughter]
Ninjas don't use nunchaku.
Nunchaku is a weapon of Okinawa.  No,
but the spear definitely has a strong advantage. It's about
3. It's mostly karate.  It's a
tool for grabbing and moving soil. Originally, you wouldn't normally use it to climb trees or fight enemies.  It's easier to climb without using your bare hands or with a rope,
isn't it?
This
[applause] [
music]
Ninja has techniques like moving from roof to roof and catching cuts from trees.  I don't
think there was such a thing as
breakable and rattling glass windows in the past.
Of course, it's important to hide.
It's true that you have to hide when you're escaping.  It's about
disturbing the earth,
so you can
burn it with fire,
sell it at stores,
set explosives, etc. So that's an
important
role.
By the way,
there is even a ninjutsu secret book called ninjutsu, which refers to the fruits used by ninjas.
After the mission is over, the
ninja quickly escapes. If you see a white
rider,
it means a ninja.  It's not about being a murderer, it
's about disturbing the enemy or searching for elements of the enemy.
It's a ninja, isn't it? This movie is also gorgeous.  It's supposed to
happen,
so in that aspect, running backwards doesn't seem to be a
mistake at
all.  The
9 o'clock mark
is an esoteric Buddhism to defeat the enemy that
protects you, isn't it
?  It's magic, so if you say it in Japanese, it's like that.  It's
been said that there were people who used animals,
but I don't think they can be used very well.  I
think it was quite difficult because there are things like this. This movie is about
4 on a scale of 1 to 10. Good job.  The
role of the shinobi is, of course, to
monitor the people, such as the
seat of the magistrate of the samurai
or to prevent flooding.
Well, that kiln, that kind of thing, that kind of thing, that kind of thing, that kind of
dark thing, and things like that kind of thing, like farming
tools, don't come here, but
digging holes in that way, you know, drilling holes
in walls like this and lighting
torches.  Let's turn it into a light so that we can have such a day alone.  The
movie where you can fight also
expresses the fighting part, right? 1 to 10
is about 4 in this movie.
No, my favorite movie
isn't this one.